41-річний Василь Давиденко став другим військовим,
який відкрито заговорив про ЛГБТ в армії.
Надихнув його на цей вчинок інший військовослужбовець -
Віктор Пилипенко, який першим порушив досі табуйовану тему.
На війні я провів більше, ніж півтора року…
Я є відкритий гей...
За рік після камінгауту ми зустрічаємо Віктора за 40 км від Києва.
Подалі від міської суєти - на дачі, де він вирощує ожину.
Психологи, я чув ще під час війни,  радять
спостерігати за тим, як природа сама себе відновлює,
це дуже насправді заспокоює.
Віктор виглядає геть інакше. Без військової форми, в цивільному.
На руці браслет райдужних кольорів.
А ще пофарбоване в синій колір волосся.
Після публічного визнання своєї сексуальної орієнтації
стались і значно важливіші зміни.
Я перестав ховатись,
я перестав брехати сам собі в першу чергу
Я тепер не боюсь ні своїх стосунків,
я ні від кого не ховаю і не думаю, не стежу за кожним словом.
аби щось про себе не виказати зайве.
Тобто, я такий, я є.
Я не відчуваю себе у напруженні постійному.
Подібну легкість відчув і Василь.
Мені стає легше.
Знаєте, це як...
От носиш на собі мішок з борошном.
От зараз я його скидаю.
Мені було років 20, напевно, коли я зрозумів, що для мене це процес незворотній,
і боротися з тим не можу.
А потім сказав: та я і не хочу з цим боротись.
Це такий, який я є.
Свій камінгаут Василь спершу зробив на фронті серед невеликої кількості побратимів.
Він не міг самотужки пережити біль від втрати коханого хлопця, який загинув на війні.
Замість засуджувати - військові підтримали його.
Так само схвально відреагували і бійці добровольчого батальйону "Донбас",
з якими служив Віктор.
І це попри те, що в лавах були відкриті гомофоби.
Коли я в своєму батальйоні сказав, що я гей і що це нічого абсолютно не змінює,
я змінив багатьох гомофобів, і вони зрозуміли,
що таке права людини і що ми боролися за вільну Україну, за конституційні права.
Сприйняли статус Віктора і його рідні.
Натомість у Василя поки не все так гладко.
На відміну від військових, новину про його гомосексуальність
і досі жваво обговорюють на роботі.
Чоловік не знає, як на це відреагує керівництво.
Не спілкується зараз і з рідними, з якими втім має й серйозні непорозуміння і конфлікти.
Коли крим окупували,
батьки все продали і переїхали в Крим.
Ми після того стосунки не підтримуємо.
Вони вважають, що я каратель, вважають, що я...
Ви розумієте - оці каратель, убивця.
Хоча...
я на своїй землі.
У мене два старших брати - офіцери російської армії.
Відповідно, ми з ними також не спілкуємося.
Але якщо побачать - привіт їм.
Нині Віктор - активіст громадської організації "Точка опори", що займається правами ЛГБТ.
Цього року планує зробити мистецький проект про права військових-геїв.
В закритій групі у Фейсбук, яку зробив Віктор, нині вже понад 40 військових-гомосексуалів,
які, поки хоч і не публічно, але готові говорити про свої проблеми.
Хлопці відчувають себе вільніше, коли спілкуються один з одним.
Деякі взагалі думали, що вони одні на весь фронт такі.
В одного взагалі дуже печальна була історія, коли він
справді не знав, що з цим робити.
Він жив життям гетеросексуальної людини. Його традиційна сім'я змусила одружитися.
Його шлюб розвалився. Він пішов на війну
і там довго не міг себе сприймати як гей.
І коли побачив мій камінгаут, написав мені…
Я йому пояснював, що він не один, що нас таких багато насправді, що це природа,
що це нормально. І мені вдаллось.
Публічні визнання змінюють українське суспільство, впевнений Віктор.
Йому б хотілось, аби на подібні вчинки наважувались й інші.
Я гадаю, що депутати, коли побачать,
коли подивляться на наші камінгаути, коли побачать, що ми також маємо свої потреби
по- перше, за відповідні закони голосуватимуть і, по-друге, самі менше боятимуться заявляти про себе,
підтримуватимуть нас і відповідні законодавчі ініціативи.
За міжнародною статистикою, геїв і лесбійок у кожному суспільстві від 5 до 7 відсотків.
Обізнаність про природу гомосексуальності в Україні ще досі низька.
У школах немає постійного предмету про сексуальне виховання,
а знання більшості українців формуються на стереотипах чи міфах,
приміром, що гомосексуали - це педофіли.
Тому, на думку Віктора і Василя, випадки побиття ЛГБТ-людей - не рідкість,
як і напади лише за те, що хтось носить райдужний прапор.